es un clima de tremenda inestabilidad
política la que se vive a esta hora aquí
en el Reino Unido el nuevo o la nueva
primera ministra será el tercero de este
año y eso nos muestra la dimensión el
tamaño de la crisis política que afronta
el país pero en especial el partido
conservador que ha estado en el gobierno
12 años la renuncia de listas no fue una
sorpresa de hecho era lo que estaban
esperando hace varias semanas sus
propios compartidarios que le eligieron
Hace seis semanas tan solo seis semanas
llevan el cargo llevaban el cargo 44
días pero también lo que estaban
pidiendo los partidos de oposición que
hoy han demandado una vez más que haya
elecciones generales para que el público
tenga la posibilidad de elegir no
solamente entre los conservadores sino
en general en las elecciones del país y
es lo mismo que están demandando aquí en
las afueras de Down Street un pequeño
grupo de Mani
se debe repetir ese mismo proceso que
vimos para la elección detrás que
sabemos acerca de esta elección Luisa
será completamente diferente El poderoso
comité 1922 del partido conservador que
se encarga de fijar las reglas bajo las
cuales un Primer Ministro puede ser
removido de su cargo a determinado hace
pocos minutos que para que una
candidatura sea seria necesita el
respaldo de al menos 100 diputados en
este momento hay 357 diputados toris en
la cámara de los comunes y es decir que
para que una candidatura tenga serias
posibilidades necesita el respaldo de
100 candidatos eso es una cantidad bien
importante y lo que quiere el partido es
hacer este proceso lo más rápido lo más
Expedito Y si hay dos candidatos o más
entonces podría convocar a las bases del
partido unas 150 mil 200 mil personas
para que voten online por el nuevo líder
pero lo que parece que sucederá es que
en este caso no habrá que llegar al
punto en que las bases del partido
llamadas y será una elección de los
propios diputados Torres brevemente
Luisa Quiénes suenan precisamente para
hacer esos candidatos
hasta el momento ninguno ha levantado la
mano y dice que quiere correr por esta
candidatura Pero se da como un hecho que
quienes compitieron con Julio entre
ellos
las llaves de down in Street también se
da como un hecho que se presentarán
Penny Morgan el propio Jeremy Hunt que
es el ministro de finanzas en este
momento fue la premierman que renunció
ayer como ministra del interior el
ministro de defensa benualas y también
que
tenía muchísimas aspiraciones y tiene
genera mucha expectativa por su futuro
en el partido conservador y ojo a esto
el posible regreso de Boris Johnson como
Primer Ministro a quien las encuestas le
dan la mayoría